[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here okay so
the title a little harsh yes but
it's true so you know the saying jack of
all trades but master of none
that is the lg g8 thin q
in a nutshell it's pretty decent at
pretty much everything in fact you
probably wouldn't regret getting one but
it doesn't stand out in any major way
for 820 bucks above the competition to
actually
give you a reason to go get one
so
yeah a little harsh but it's true so you
can start with the design of this phone
it's nothing special it's familiar to a
lot of people who have seen other lg or
2019 phones it's a slab of glass with
rounded corners there's a power button
and a good place volume rocker on the
other side google assistant below those
so there's absolutely nothing wrong with
it at all it's just very plain you know
like i hate to encourage you know going
crazy or making weird choices just to be
different in design but i feel like
maybe they need a bit of a stronger
identity here like if i asked you to
describe an lg phone in a couple words
what even comes to mind really you know
so i'll say this red color definitely
pretty cool it is also still a
fingerprint magnet though like the other
colors which are gray and black but also
the cameras on the back are totally flat
so this is one of few phones i can
actually say they really have no camera
bump at all so this is one of them which
is nice but i also think it makes it the
sneaky slipperiest phone of all time but
other than that nothing really stands
out to me you know it's a design it's a
smartphone so you get a 6.1 inch display
up front and it's quite good it's super
high resolution 1440p and plenty bright
not the brightest but it's viewable
outdoors and with a very average notch
up at the top and we'll talk more about
why the notch is so big in a bit but the
side bezels are a little bit more than
slim it's kind of feeling like the
galaxy s10e or the iphone 10r as far as
bezel size anyway
and then the normal stuff at the bottom
is which you'd see in any other lg phone
you still have your usbc still your
boombox speaker still your headphone
jack backed by a high quality dac this
phone is ip68 water resistant and it
still has wireless charging overall the
build is good it's not really like
missing anything although there are two
things to note one this boombox speaker
it still has at the bottom for some
reason sounds worse to me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i don't know it's worse than i remember
like it's pretty flat and hollow
sounding and of course it still comes
from the bottom corner of the phone so
it's easy to block by accident but
number two the other thing is if you
actually look up at the top of the phone
where the earpiece normally is this
phone doesn't have one instead they have
a speaker behind the glass called
crystal sound oled which fires from sort
of the top third of the phone which to
my ear sounded just like a normal phone
call in terms of quality and volume but
i could also sort of hear this buzzing
like a thin rattling sound that you
don't normally hear in a normal speaker
so that's the first time i've actually
heard one of these replacement speakers
sound a bit weird but it's not a deal
breaker for me because i don't make that
many phone calls in the first place and
the bonus is it can sort of act like
bone conduction and it works in more
than just the top eighth of the phone
okay so the specs ready snapdragon 855
six gigs of ram
128 3500
they're fine there's no upgraded version
with like eight gigs of ram or something
and if you want more storage you have to
go with microsd which is kind of a
bummer considering we have phones with
way more internal storage for people who
do lots of things on their phones and
the battery size it's fine it's not
pushing the limits or anything it's
bigger than the galaxy s10s battery but
it's not pushing the
4200 milliamp hours we see on some other
big phones so the specs are fine and the
performance through lg software has been
pretty smooth and and predictable except
for scrolling for some reason so overall
i think lg skin is fine again i've used
that word a lot it hasn't changed much
since last year so the settings app is
still a little overwhelming it still
buries some things but for the most part
things flow pretty smoothly and you can
easily get used to it but for some
reason the scrolling physics especially
in the app drawer are super stuttery and
it's been a while now and really weird
for a new phone like this to straight up
stutter so i almost feel like this is a
bug since the rest of the phone is fine
but yeah definitely got to mention that
overall though performance just using
the phone every day through lg software
it's fine now i don't want to make this
just a list of reasons not to buy this
phone so some of the good stuff or my
favorite things about this phone are on
the back and it's the two cameras lg was
one of the first to consistently do that
ultra wide over the years that we're
just now starting to see on the backs of
phones everywhere and they still do it
the sad thing for them is it was so easy
to copy that now everyone just added an
ultra wide and they're now all caught up
it's not like lg mastered the ultra wide
in any special way so the cameras here
are pretty fun but they're not
incredibly unique or anything but i like
the consistency of these cameras it's a
confident shooter it's fast the color
science is pretty good it doesn't over
expose that often and the similarity in
color between the 12 megapixel standard
camera and the 16 megapixel ultrawide i
think is actually better than huawei's
and samsung's and even in the camera ui
is the nice little things like the zoom
with the shutter icon that are a nice
touch the camera is good in the g8 and
again so many others have gotten so good
that you just have to wonder about the
ones who don't get it right like the
razers and onepluses of the world but i
guess that's a rant for another video
now if you've noticed pretty much
everything so far about this phone's
been it's good it's fine you know so you
would think there's got to be something
about this phone that takes it to the
next level that really makes it stand
out above the rest to make it lg's
flagship
so i guess for lg those things are
hand id
and air motion
yeah so the notch up here in the phone
is so big because lg has dropped a few
extra sensors up there including a
time-of-flight camera and then an
infrared blaster and a receiver to be
able to read and identify and track your
hand and its movement so with hand id
you're supposed to be able to just hover
it over your phone to unlock it and with
air motion you're supposed to be able to
open apps and control media and things
like that without touching your phone
and i will say it is a cool idea i kind
of wish it worked better than it did but
in practice as you can probably
understand from my tone and from the
first impressions video
it's far from ideal it's usable at best
but it's not good so with hand id first
i mean it works but you have to hold
your hand in a very specific distance
and spot around in front of the phone
and the learning curve even for me was
just a bit too much and it just makes
you not want to use it plus straight up
the feedback on the screen to help you
correct yourself is blocked by your hand
that you're trying to unlock it with so
yeah i mean it has a fingerprint reader
on the back i just turned off hand id
and use the regular fingerprint reader
like i think most people will and then
air motion to be fair it seems to be a
tiny bit more responsive than when i
first tried it in the impressions video
a little while ago specifically the
volume knob actually seems to be more
responsive now and easier to trigger
correctly and then the twisting motion
tracks really well which is awesome but
the rest of it like the waving to the
left or right to open apps or take your
screenshot it's not really better than
just using the buttons on the phone or
even better using the google assistant
button that's already there on the side
of the phone to just ask it to open an
app for you it's probably faster also
this is how long it takes to
pause something that's playing so you
have music playing oh someone calls you
oh wait hold on one second let me just
let me just pause uh the music give me a
second hold up pause
what was that
yeah you might as well just
just hit the button so yeah at the end
of the day it seems tough to even say
the g8 is worth buying
even though it's a pretty good phone
like overall the g8 does have a good
build quality it has good software and a
good set of cameras all around but
that's just a testament to how good
phones have gotten around it over the
past couple years i think in my heart it
feels unfair to say oh the pixel has a
better camera and the p30 has a bigger
battery and the galaxy s10 has a
headphone jack like you're pulling from
all these different phones to try to
beat up on this little guy and say it's
not good so i'll make it simple for you
if you were thinking about buying an lg
g8
just buy a galaxy s10e instead because
there isn't a single thing that this
phone does better than the s10e
and the s10 is cheaper like the g8 has a
regular and an ultrawide camera that are
pretty good the s10e has those too and
they're just as good the display on the
g8 is pretty good it's very big and it's
high resolution but the display on the
s10e is excellent it has less of a notch
it has smaller bezels better colors and
better brightness the g8 has a headphone
jack but so does the s10e the
fingerprint reader on the back is pretty
standard and it's better than hand id
but i'd argue the fingerprint reader and
the power button of the s10e is better
the battery life is fine here and it's
fine there you know the software samsung
software just got a lot better and lg's
just kind of staying the same so there's
no real reason that stands out to buy an
lg g8 over that phone and vane id isn't
it sorry hand id just not the one now if
this phone was 700 bucks or 650 then the
reason to buy it would be that it's
cheaper than the rest that would be its
main advantage but even that's not true
yet now i think with lg's history and
kind of knowing where this phone's at
that may eventually be the case with
discounts but until that happens
don't buy an lg g8 jack of all trades
master of none
thanks for watching catch you guys the
next one
peace